[Musica]
in una qualche occasione avrete avuto
necessità di documentare il possesso di
titoli di qualsiasi genere titoli
culturali di studio di servizio e
qualche difficoltà penso e immagino
abbiate avuta però nell'ordinamento
italiano è stato introdotto una norma
negli ultimi anni che semplifica di
molto la vita al cittadino la cosiddetta
autocertificazione l'autocertificazione
però è una documentazione che si
rilascia conoscendo puntualmente gli
elementi che si devono dichiarare perché
tutto quello che si autocertifica
inesattamente o che non corrisponde al
vero è perseguibile
la legge stessa che l'ha introdotta
naturalmente a garanzia della corretta
attivazione di un procedimento
amministrativo ha previsto anche che le
dichiarazioni inesatte o non veritiere
siano siano perseguibili
io immagino la mia persona no se dovessi
autocertificare il diploma di maturità
secondaria di secondo grado non avrei
nessuna difficoltà
ricordo perfettamente alla scuola dove
ho conseguito ricordo esattamente l'anno
scolastico di conseguimento e ricordo
esattamente il voto qualche difficoltà
in più ce l'avrei col diploma di licenza
media per esempio rimanendo nell'ambito
di quelli che sono gli esempi
dell'autodichiarazione dei titoli di
studio
un episodio un signore simpaticissimo si
è recato presso i nostri uffici perché
aveva proprio il bisogno di entrare in
possesso di alcuni dati aveva smarrito
il diploma di licenza media
e vero lui conosceva le regole
sull'autocertificazione voleva
autocertificare il possesso di questo
titolo ma essendo un cittadino modello
non si è sentito di farlo non conoscendo
puntualmente non ricordando puntualmente
quale era l'anno in cui l'aveva
conseguito e soprattutto la votazione
finale è venuto in segreteria e ci ha
chiesto il rilascio di un certificato di
diploma voi penserete nulla di più
normale per una pubblica amministrazione
che rilasciare una certificazione
sì oggi i dati che occorrono per
generare una certificazione guardate che
c'è una differenza tra dati e
certificati
il dato è l'elemento conoscitivo che
consente di generare un documento
amministrativo valido
ora quando i dati non sono memorizzati
in una banca dati scusate il gioco di
parole vanno ricostruiti sulla base di
registri obbligatori presenti ora il
collega ha dovuto fare una ricerca del
registro che conteneva i dati di cui il
signore aveva bisogno non è stato facile
per una ragione perché non ricordandosi
l'anno del signore abbiamo riku dovuto
ricostruire qual era l'anno in cui
poteva essere stati annotati quei quei
dati e l'abbiamo ritrovato sommando
all'anno di nascita del signore gli anni
che occorrono per conseguire il titolo
di studio la situazione di disagio è
stata sicuramente per il cittadino
perché innanzitutto non abitando più nel
comune dove avevano sede degli uffici di
segreteria si è dovuto recare impiegato
del tempo personale guardato il tempo
oggi si dice il tempo è denaro ma è vero
il tempo di quel signore è stato
sprecato perché ha dovuto raggiungere
uffici di segreteria che puntualmente
hanno dovuto ricevere una istanza ma da
quest'altra parte da parte
dell'amministrazione è stato impiegato
anche lì del tempo importante dove
incastrandosi con l'attivita ordinaria
dell'amministrazione il collega ha
dovuto procedere con questa ricerca in
più l'angoscia del signore a non
ricevere in tempo la certificazione
occorrente per l'istruttoria della
pratica che stava documentando come
avrete potuto intuire
io mi occupo di organizzare i servizi di
un'istituzione scolastica e ne sono
direttamente responsabile lavoro presso
l'istituto comprensivo di ospitaletto
negli ultimi anni sto cercando di dare
una mano e collaborare per il
miglioramento dei servizi amministrativi
ecco in uno degli incontri con esperti
di sistemi informativi perché stiamo
progettando rilasciando un servizio di
firma elettronica avanzata per i
possessori di sfida
un'altra rivoluzione all'interno del
sistema scuola che consentirà una volta
per tutte dare concreta attuazione alle
regole tecniche del cad e fare in modo
che la pubblica amministrazione generi
fin dall'inizio documenti digitali che
abbiano pieno valore legale nel corso
degli incontri per arrivare a generare
quel servizio di firma elettronica
avanzata sono venuti a conoscenza che
l'unione europea
utilizzando la tecnologia block chain ha
creato un infrastruttura che può
organizzare il deposito di titoli o di
certificazioni sicuri e protetti in
italia questo servizio lo garantisce
cimea che è il centro di informazione
per la mobilità è l'equivalenza e dei
titoli accademici
ora cosa fa cimea ha attivato un
progetto che è sì è stato battezzato
diplomi diplomi e stato attivato già da
diversi enti e università italiane noi
dell'istituto comprensivo di ospitaletto
abbiamo fin da subito voluto partecipare
a questo progetto devo dire che ho
ricevuto e ho registrato la
disponibilità e l'entusiasmo della
dirigente scolastica dei miei colleghi
in ufficio
qual era l'obiettivo quello di cercare
di migliorare i servizi che noi
riusciamo ad erogare ai cittadini ma
soprattutto anche fare da pionieri da
sperimentatore per nuove buone pratiche
per i miei colleghi per le istituzioni
immaginate a un istituto di secondo
grado che riesce a rilasciare questo
servizio ai suoi studenti ha risolto un
problema atavico per quello che riguarda
il rilascio di continue di continue
autocertificazioni detto dell'esempio
che abbiamo citato poco fa vi voglio
descrivere brevemente per farvi
comprendere qual è la semplicità di
attivazione del servizio di utilizzo del
servizio stesso
sul sito dell'istituto comprensivo di
ospitaletto abbiamo predisposto una
paginetta semplice dal quale si può
accedere direttamente al sito di cime a
dove è depositato il servizio dei
diplomi
registrarsi è semplice basta indicare un
indirizzo di posta elettronica valido e
generare una password
la pubblica amministrazione
e stare attenta quando rilascia le
certificazioni abbiamo pensato di
organizzare il controllo dei dati di
richiedendo in una maniera semplice se
la scuola conosce già l'indirizzo è
quindi il domicilio digitale utilizzato
dal richiedente
beh la famiglia o lo studente non deve
fare nient'altro perché quello è un
domicilio digitale già utilizzato nei
rapporti scuola famiglia e quindi in
qualsiasi caso è sempre dimostrabile che
l'identità del richiedente è certa dopo
essersi registrati al servizio diploma
il soggetto che che ha necessità di
usufruire di questo servizio si logga si
fa riconoscere il richiede le
certificazioni che la scuola deve o in
qualche modo può rilasciare sono
elencati in una casella si scelgono se
ne possono scegliere anche
contestualmente più di una e allo stesso
momento in cui viene confermata la
richiesta di certificazione alla scuola
viene notificata viene fatto conoscere
l'esistenza di una richiesta a scuola
entra
compila un form dove sono contenuti i
dati essenziali perché si possa generare
questa certificazione o addirittura lega
un pdf
ecco in questo stesso momento
all'interessato viene comunque fatto
sapere che il titolo è pronto che cosa
fate a questo momento in poi
l'interessato ha costruito un portfolio
wallet dove li dentro per tutta la vita
aveva conservato poi le certificazioni
che ha richiesto all istituto
comprensivo di ospitaletto che ne fa li
spende nel tempo e nello spazio come e
quando vuole
immaginiamo la situazione che abbiamo
descritto all'inizio se fosse stata una
lunga dell'istituto comprensivo di
ospitaletto quella certificazione
l'avremmo depositata nel wallet del
signore pincopallo in qualsiasi momento
della sua vita
lunga questo signore avrebbe potuto e
potrebbe condividerlo da qui al prossimo
futuro con chiunque ha titolo a sapere
che lui ha un diploma di licenza media
i vantaggi per il cittadino sono chiari
ed evidenti
non trascuriamo li rivedremo tra un
attimo anche i vantaggi che ci sono per
la pubblica amministrazione in più
stiamo cercando di fare un passo avanti
nel sollecitare perché guardate quando
poi si scoprono le utilità delle
tecnologie
bisogna spingersi in avanti utilizzarlo
è sempre nel miglior modo possibile
ora nel prossimo futuro grazie alla
collaborazione fattiva dei produttori di
software per i servizi di segreteria
gli studenti oli famiglie potranno già
nel corso del della frequenza degli anni
di studio a consentire richiedere il
rilascio la costruzione di un volet dove
alla fine quando si è conseguito il
titolo automaticamente venga depositato
oggi giorno il termine burocrazia e
associato all'inefficienza della
pubblica amministrazione mi permetto di
dirvi da convinto servitori dello stato
che non è così
io dico che è necessario che un iter sia
burocratizzato burocratizzato io intendo
che sia codificato puntualmente
precisamente chi deve fare che cosa
altrimenti si opererebbe nella terra di
nessuno e il cittadino non ha nessuna
garanzia del corretto procedimento
amministrativo
detto questo vorrei portarvi un esempio
concreto si sono prodotte delle domande
per generare graduatorie per aspiranti
supplenti i docenti gli insegnanti
sapete tutti che ci sono state
grandissime polemiche l'avvio dell'anno
scolastico ordinato non ordina i docenti
ci sono non ci sono bene la procedura
informatica devi aiutare a velocizzare
ad efficientare
questa operazione di inizio anno
ora è capitato questo si sono generate
una mole di autocertificazione per la
verità con un po di autocritica
compilando uno schema di
autocertificazione che non conduceva
puntualmente all'identificazione delle
situazioni realmente esistente questo
cosa ha prodotto a prodotto che sono
state generate pubblicate e applicate
utilizzate graduatorie che includevano
aspiranti che non ne avevano titolo
guardate i provvedimenti sono pubblicati
sul sito dell'anpi dell'ufficio di
ambito territoriale di pesce sono
puntualmente verificabili questo che
cosa sta a significare che è vero vanno
progettate le procedure informatizzate
per agevolare il cittadino ma vanno
progettati in maniera puntuale per fare
in modo che il tempo davvero si utilizzo
nella maniera corretta non si sprechi
tempo da parte chi deve compilare ma non
si utilizzi male il tempo da parte
dell'amministrazione che deve rincorrere
le certificazioni prodotte in modo
inesatto verificarle escludere gli
aspiranti che non ne hanno titolo
generando anche un sentimento di astio
nei confronti dell'amministrazione
mi hai dato l'idea che io potessi fare
l'insegnante non era vero qual è il
motivo per cui non lo posso fare e non
se ne esce più
si potrebbe utilizzare abbiamo detto
tante volte ma è questo il nocciolo
della questione il tempo perché il tempo
risparmiato si utilizza per migliorare
ed offrire servizi aggiuntivi al
cittadino
io vi ringrazio vi ringrazio davvero per
il tempo che avete impegnato ad
ascoltarmi e vi saluto
arrivederci ciao